we I just got back from Appleton you
know we just got back from Appleton I
say we sometimes you know I don't like
to feel alone so saying we kind of puts
me in a in a groupthink space in my head
Appleton Wisconsin in Wisconsin that's
you know that's dairy that's the dairy
belt you know you you you'll step on you
you'll you'll step in something outside
you might go what is that and it's just
nothing that's a little bit of 2% you'll
see some stray yogurt just you know a
chunk of yogurt just kind of roll them
down a hillside you it's it's it's kind
of baffling you you know you'll be
talking to somebody and suddenly just
you know some skim milk will just fall
right out their mouth or a cheese curdle
just you know a magician will walk up
and just you know pull a cheese curd out
from behind your ear and that's
Wisconsin that's up there and that's
those dairy the this the dairy people
and they love dairy up there and they
love to just I mean like you and I we
probably would look at a cow and just
think oh that's an animal but those
people up there they look at a cow and
they'd be like oh look at this
[__] right here this little milk
jug with hoofs we had a so all sold out
shows all sold out shows in Appleton
Wisconsin and thanks thanks thanks for
for the joining people you know a bunch
of different people come out fast Steve
came out I think his name was fast even
fat Chris I can't remember but this
gentleman this gentleman sent me a uh a
DM and he goes hey man just letting you
know I'm coming through Saturday night
numb won't be the fattest [__] dude
you'll see a whole weekend and I want to
give a check mate to that man because he
he honored his word I mean this guy did
I patted him on the back and and then I
had to tell him I patted him on the back
because he couldn't feel it
I mean his dude was huge and beautiful
anymore a big kind of bright bright
green you know safety green you know the
funny thing is when people get
and I'm not saying this to shame this
gentleman at all he was in a good mood
about it and so and so we can laugh with
him and he said look I'm gonna be you
know imma be a fan as felon you know I'm
gonna be the fattest the fattest sugar
hole in the enamel you know I'm gonna be
the fattest cavity and he was and he
came out with his daddy and his daddy
looked you know like somebody from you
know the Hobbit a little bit kind of a
handsome sort of older gentleman but you
know a very Midwestern just a smile on
his face he had a built-in smile you
know like somebody was just kind of like
you know like the Lord was just kind of
tickling him under his chin and they
came out and they enjoyed themselves in
that big fella he was wearing a bright
green because if you notice sometime
when people get real large a lot of the
colors that they can wear our safety
colors bright orange you know you'll see
some black people they'll be real large
and they'll wear bright orange you know
or you know Shawn dresses she'll have
bright bright green and you're like dang
what size is that and this this fella
wasn't no different he came out and he
had he had the he had that safety green
kind of like emergency kind of green you
know if you you know if there was like
police at night by the side of the road
and they have flares and stuff and
something bad happen and then also
they're wearing green vests he had that
color green because when you get past
three XL and stuff like that all the
colors they put on your safety because I
think you know it's uh here's you're
probably a little bit of a of a health
risk I think it's certain you know it's
certain poundage --is but it was good
that he came out man you know it was
good that he came out because everybody
enjoyed it man I and it was a it started
to get chilly it snowed it snowed one
day so that was really awesome
but fat Pete came out little Nolan they
had these dudes that this kind of like I
don't know fraternity dudes a spit in
each other's mouth
is that like point-blank range so they
said it was like a you know a trick that
they did but I didn't see the real it
didn't see much you know like too much
trickery to me it just seemed like a
couple dudes just spitting in each
other's mouths you know it seemed like
something you know a bit of a dark art
you'd find him one of the in the
crevices of the Internet but yeah a
little Nolan came out vixie does gal
Vic's he came through who else that lady
they kept crying
there was a lady they kept crying for no
for no reason after the show and she had
I think she'd been you know drinking and
eating at the same time which is popular
and I you know when I used to really you
know ingest booze I would do it and she
was drying her tears with a with a
hamburger bun and there's something
honestly sexy about that when you see a
lady's emotions just flowing out of her
face
and she just dabbing them [__] up
with a with a top half of a crescent
roll yeah ma'am erection erection town
that's where I'm headed who else Oh some
twins I met some dudes over twins and
I'll say this you know I'm talking about
twins before if you're twins
[__] fight it out you know so many
times you see twins they're both living
they're both just kind of carrying on
with their existences or existence i I'm
not sure what the term is but [__]
fight it out if you're twins fight it
out be you know obviously God wants
y'all to compete and especially this
time of year [__] figure it out you
know two people enter one person leaves
turn the holidays into a real you know
into a real fiesta I just think that a
lot of times twins these days back in
the old days if you saw twins you'd see
them fist fighting you know I remember
you drive down the street and they'd see
a couple twins over there [__] if you
saw triplets they'd have swords out in
the yard
because people it was more about you
know survival of the fittest there's no
way three of us are gonna just meander
around town just each of us you know
taking a eight hours a you know an
eight-hour shift of at the same life
each day no you got to just you got to
have your own life so it's time to cut
corners so I'm just saying if your Twins
figure it out figure it out thank you
guys for checking out this clip and if
you want to see another clip then you
can look at this clip or this clip
either one of these so did you pick one
or he's still just watching me do this
cuz it's alarming